y senador buenas noches gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 le
pregunto qué fue lo que sucedió y
quiénes fueron los que los atacaron
gracias un saludo muy fraterno hace
aproximadamente dos horas cuando una
chiva un bus escalera un vehículo
se dirigía de la ciudad de cali al cauca
regresando ya con el personal
fue agredida por personas de civil
apoyados por la policía nacional
contrario a lo que dice el señor
presidente de la república pero los
civiles vestidos de camisetas blancas
que dispararon contra la población que
iba en el vehículo inmediatamente la
archiva frenó la gente se bajó y trató
de confrontar a los que estaban
disparando por eso se presentó los
heridos tenemos nueve personas heridas
están recluidas en las diferentes
clínicas de la ciudad de cali y una
compañera coordinadora del movimiento
juvenil del cauca es la que está en
estado crítico en este momento pero como
las imágenes lo muestran
fueron civiles respaldados por la fuerza
pública que le dispararon a la gente y
la gente la comunidad los indígenas y
valen las chivas regresándose al cauca
si en ningún momento fue la gente de las
comunidades indígenas que disparó atacó
o pretendió tomarse las instalaciones de
las casas que en ese sector había ahora
ahora senador le pregunto si van a
reunirse con los ministros que viajaron
a la ciudad de cali cuáles son sus
peticiones específicas al gobierno del
presidente iván duque
hasta ahorita la minga indígena está
reunida en las instalaciones de la
universidad del valle analizando la
situación pero aún no se ha considerado
sentarse a hablar con los ministros
que llegaron a cal dispuesto que los
ministros no resuelven nada el ministro
de defensa le obedece al ex senador
álvaro uribe vélez quien por su cuenta
de twitter ha estado de manera
insistente casi coordinando lo ordenando
lo que ataque a la fuerza pública aceite
no valdría la pena sentarse a hablar con
ministros que no tienen capacidad de
decisión y en su defecto la minga el
comando nacional de paro está convocando
al señor presidente de la república y a
todo su gabinete para iniciar diálogos
que detengan la situación que se está
presentando en el país si ahora le
pregunto un senador lo siguiente cuál es
la respuesta que le dan a las personas
que reciben en cali y están diciendo que
están secuestradas y no pueden acceder a
los alimentos y a combustibles por
cuenta de estos bloqueos
hay que tener en cuenta que lo que está
sucediendo en cali no es agenciado o
auspiciado por la minga la minga está en
cali en las vías
conducen a buenaventura a popayán a
bogotá están bloqueando en los
camioneros porque ellos también se
vincularon a la jornada de paro nacional
no es la minga que está bloqueando las
vías en este momento la minga está
apoyando los puntos de resistencia que
hay dentro de la ciudad de cali y en
cali el transporte está normal los
vehículos pueden movilizarse de manera
tranquila pero los bloqueos son por
parte de las tractomulas y camiones que
están atravesadas en las vías